Spyware für alle. Auf der Enthüllungsplattform WikiLeaks ist eine Version der Spionage-Software Finfische aufgetaucht. Diese wird angeblich an Geheimdienste verkauft, um Handys und Computer von Zielpersonen überwachen zu können. Die Software funktioniert dabei als klassischer Trojaner. Auch ein Baukasten für zur Infektion der Zielgeräte ist Teil des Software-Paketes. In der Vergangenheit waren bereits Support-Dokumente des Herstellers Gamma im Internet aufgetaucht. Mit dem aktuellen Leak ist es nun möglich, dass sich interessierte Hacker und Aktivisten die Software genauer anschauen. Vielleicht gibt es ja ähnlich interessante Ergebnisse wie damals beim Bundestrojaner. Neue Super-Sicherheitslücke Shellshock ist eine neue Sicherheitslücke, die es erlaubt, viele Rechner anzugreifen, die mit UNIX-ähnlichen Betriebssystemen betrieben werden. Dazu zählt auch Apples Betriebssystem OS X. Durch Shellshock ist es möglich, auf fremden Rechnern eigene Programmcode auszuführen und das kann man ausnutzen, um Rechner komplett zu übernehmen. Trotz einer Software-Aktualisierung besteht das Problem immer noch. Falls ihr davon betroffen seid, solltet ihr die nächsten Tage also Ausschau nach einem endgültigen Update halten. Das iPhone in der Mikrowelle Die Polizei von Los Angeles hat offiziell davor gewarnt, iPhones zum Aufladen in die Mikrowelle zu legen. Falls ihr euch fragt, wie man überhaupt auf die Idee kommen kann, vor einigen Tagen geistete ein Scherzbild durchs Internet, laut dem man angeblich per Apple Wave den Akku des Handys in der Mikrowelle aufladen kann. Und anscheinend gab es tatsächlich ein paar Leute, die das geglaubt haben, was zu eingangs erwähnter Warnung der Polizei von Los Angeles führte.
Liebe Kinder, bitte versucht das nicht. Steamy von Ninety Wines hier im Chaos Radio Fritz, dem Blue Moon, wo es heute der Chaos Computer Club ist, wie er hier um Vintage Computing geht. Also wir gucken uns ein bisschen alte Computer an. Zu Gast sind dabei Zeltophil. Hallo, guten Abend. Und Lanimo.
Guten Abend.
Wir haben schon ein bisschen gesprochen, dass Vintage Computing halt, da geht es darum, wie alte Computer gearbeitet haben, dass man das mal nach erleben kann. Wir haben schon gehört, wie man das macht. Man kann es emulieren, also einfach durch Software, man kann es auch wirklich selber nachbauen. Wir haben auch schon gehört, dass Disketten ein schwieriges Thema sind. Also noch nicht, weil es gibt noch genug, aber immer mal irgendwann werden könnte. Und wie das so ist mit der Archivierung von Computern, die funktionieren überhaupt. Und jetzt sagte, zählt so viel gerade noch, während die Mikros aus waren, man kann ja Disketten auch in den Backofen tun. Entschuldigung, bitte was?
Das Problem ist halt, dass die magnetische Beschichtung davon so runterflockt. Und da ist auch ein Bindemittel drauf. Das wird halt einfach trocken oder ich weiß nicht, wie man das sagen soll. Aber wenn man das ein paar Stunden in den Backofen legt und wirklich genau auf die Temperatur achtet und da drin backen lässt, dann schmilzt sich das da alles wieder so zurecht. Das machen auch ganz viele die Audiofreaks mit ihren Tapes und so, aber auch halt für Datentapes und für Disketten kann man das machen. Und was die Leute dafür einsetzen, sind zum Teil so Obst-Trocken-Maschinen.
Gibt es noch mehr so eine Handwerkstricks für das Videobeleben alter Computer? Ich habe tatsächlich mal, also es ist jetzt nicht wirklich vintage, aber für die PlayStation 3 habe ich sowas auch mal gehört. Ich hatte so ein Hitzeproblem und da hat gesagt, ja, das ist eine kalte Lötstelle. Da könnte einfach die Platine irgendwie 40 Minuten bei 380 Grad in den Ofen legen, dann geht das wieder. Gibt es noch, also Disketten, Luft trocknen? Okay, gibt es noch mehr so eine Tricks?
Ja, also ich habe mal gehört, dass man Festplatten auch mit Wärme, wenn die verharzte Lage haben, dass man das, dass es auch angeblich helfen soll. Also ich war jetzt noch nicht so in so einer Situation. Also entweder die Festplatten, die waren unrettbar verloren oder sie gingen noch.
Ist das jetzt eigentlich bei den, ja?
Im Zweifelsfall willst du das aber bei Festplatten, wenn dir deine Daten heilig sind, eh in einen professionellen Betrieb überlassen. Also der es noch genug gibt, weil es noch genug Festplatten gibt. Wie das dann mit SSDs später aussieht, ist eine andere Sache. Aber ich glaube, wenn deine Daten heilig sind.
Nicht im Backofenleben, das ist schon was für die Basterds.
Bei den Firmen zahlt man aber vierstellige Beträge dafür.
Nee, es geht ja darum, wenn dir die wirklich heilig sind. Wenn es mal nett wäre, ist es okay.
Wir reden aber jetzt von guten unterschiedlichen Sachen. Was du meinst, ist ja sozusagen, meine Festplatte geht mir kaputt. Also verharzte Festplatten bewegt, wenn die beweglichen Teile sich verharzen, das passiert wahrscheinlich nur bei wirklich großem Alter.
Es geht ja auch eher darum, bei dieser ganzen Sache die Festplatte wieder ans Laufen zu kriegen. Die Daten sind ja meistens nicht so super wichtig. Also es gibt natürlich Situationen, da ist beides wichtig, aber eigentlich geht es ja um die Hardware, die man erhalten will.
Okay, ich sage das jetzt auch nur prophylaktisch. Wir hatten es gerade vom iPhone und der Mikrofelle.
Okay, liebe Hörer, wir gehen aus, dass ihr klug genug seid zu wissen, dass ihr eure wirklich guten, wichtigen Festplatten nicht in den Backofen tut. Aber wir haben es trotzdem jetzt noch mal gesagt. Wo wir gerade jetzt dabei sind, wir reden jetzt von Festplatten und Disketten. Und Festplatten gibt es heute immer noch. Disketten hat man vielleicht schon mal gesehen oder davon gehört. Arbeitet ihr auch mit anderen Datenträgern? Also es gab da früher auch noch Magnetbänder und Lochkarten. Oder ist das dann schon wieder zu vintage für euch?
Ja, auf jeden Fall Tapes. Da gibt es ja auch ganz verschiedene Formate. Ja, Lochkarten, Lochbänder. Das habe ich aber nicht bei mir zu Hause. Das haben wir auch nicht bei uns im Hackerspace oder so. Aber es gibt auf jeden Fall Hobbyisten, die sowas benutzen. Dann magneto-optische Laufwerke gibt es ja auch noch.
Wie sieht der Datenträger da aus?
Im Prinzip auch so, Scheiben halt.
Also auch zu Archivzwecken, sogenannte Worms, Bright Wands. Also du kannst diese Dinger nur einmal schreiben.
Wie ein ZD-Brennen quasi.
So in der Art, hat aber noch ein paar andere Vorteile, die jetzt ein bisschen komplexer sind. Du hast Archivsicherheit. Die garantieren dir auch eine relativ lange Haltbarkeit. Also das willst du halt als Unternehmen machen. Das macht man glaube ich nicht mehr. Aber das hat man bis vor ein paar Jahren gemacht. Wenn du wichtige Daten archivieren musst, auch so, dass sie über das ja auch in 10, 20 Jahren auch noch für juristische Zwecke lesbar sind. Also da musst du ja auch gesetzliche Vorgaben als Unternehmen erfüllen für gewisse Dokumente.
So, jetzt haben wir über Computernachbau und Datenträger gesprochen. Ihr seid wie gesagt auch aufgerufen anzurufen, wenn ihr selber ein Vintage Computing Erlebnis habt oder nochmal zurückschwelgen wollt zu eurem ersten Computer. 0331777110. Es hat auch den Nils genau dazu angerufen. Nils aus Neukölln. Hallo und guten Abend. Wir haben ja hier sozusagen am Anfang gesagt, es gibt vier so große Themen, nämlich Emulatoren, Homecomputerszene, Großrechner und Arcade-Automaten und Spielekonsolen. Zu diesem Thema hast du angerufen, wenn ich richtig informiert bin.
Also insbesondere Spielekonsolen, Arcade-Automaten habe ich zwar schon genutzt, aber bin ich jetzt nicht so der Sammler von... Ja, kurz eine Erwähnung erst mal. Eine Sache kurz vorher noch zu dem NTSC versus Pyle. Bei Spielekonsolen macht es wirklich viel aus, weil das macht 12% Unterschied in der Geschwindigkeit. Und wenn die Spiele nicht angepasst sind, dann wird auch die Musik langsamer, was man dann z.B. in YouTube-Videos zu Sonic sieht, ein Spiel fürs Mega-Dreif, wenn sich dann die Amerikaner fragen, ob man irgendwie auf Drogen ist oder so, weil die ganze Musik einfach mal ein Stück langsamer ist, als sie es gewohnt sind.
Wenn man sozusagen ein amerikanisches Spiel auf der europäischen Hardware spielt?
Nein, wenn man ein europäisches Spiel ganz normal spielt auf unserer Hardware, dann ist es durch die 50 Hz, die wir hier verwenden, 12% langsamer, wenn es nicht angepasst worden ist, als das Spiel im Original.
Okay, verstehe. Du beschäftigst dich damit mit alten Konsolen, wie man spielen kann. Du bist auch Teil eines Podcasts, der dich damit beschäftigt.
Genau. Ich bin Teil vom Retro-Circle. Ich mache das mit zwei Freunden zusammen. Wir sprechen einmal im Monat über ein ausgewähltes Spiel. Es sind 8-16-Bit-Konsolen und teilweise auch Heimcomputerspiele, aber hauptsächlich aus dem LucasArts-Bereich.
Wenn ihr das macht, schwägt ihr das auch in Erinnerung oder spielt ihr das Spiel jeweils noch mal durch?
Wir spielen nach Möglichkeit das Spiel noch mal durch. Entweder je nachdem, welche Hardware man zur Verfügung hat auf Originalkonsole oder einem Emulator. Ein Emulator hat natürlich den Vorteil, dass man da auch mal zwischendrin abspeichern kann und wieder laden und dadurch das Spiel einfach mal schneller durchspielen kann, also auf der Originalkonsole. Aber das Feeling ist halt schon auf der Originalkonsole ein anderes. Ich habe hier auch auf meinem Tisch direkt vor mir irgendwie ein N64 und Super Nintendo und zwei alte Game Boys liegen, die vor einem Fernseher stehen.
Das heißt, du würdest die Original-Hardware immer vorziehen, einem Emulator?
Kommt auf den Einsatzweck drauf an. Also zum Beispiel, ich habe da jetzt ein längeres Rollenspiel vor mir und das habe ich im Original für Super Nintendo und ich werde es dann wahrscheinlich trotzdem im Emulator spielen, weil ich es dann auf meinem Telefon spielen kann, weil ich immer dabei habe. Und auf der Original-Hardware habe ich dann vielleicht eine Stunde am Abend oder so und auf meinem Telefon habe ich es halt in den ganzen U-Bahn-Fahrten und so etwas noch mit dabei. Aber an sich ist Original-Hardware schon besser als Emulator. Es gibt auch Leute, die so ein bisschen abschätzig gucken, gerade in der Retro-Spiele-Bereich, wenn die Leute mit Emulatoren spielen, weil ich aber nicht ganz so verstehen kann, auch wenn es ab und zu Probleme gibt mit Emulatoren.
Gibt es denn auch diese Zwischenstufe? Jetzt gibt es ja gerade zu sagen, entweder du hast die Original-Hardware oder du spielst auf deinem Smartphone. Gibt es auch dieses, wir bauen Original-Hardware nach und schließen Kontrolle an einen modernen Rechner an?
Da gibt es zwar mehrere Zwischenstufen. Fangen wir doch mal an. Man kann ja den Emulator haben und dann holt man sich einen USB-Adapter, um sein Original-Pad an den Rechner anzuschließen, was es schon mal ein bisschen besser macht. Also allein vom Gefühl her. Dann gibt es so ein Ding, das nennt sich Retro, wird leider nicht mehr hergestellt. Da kann man ein Original-Modul reinstecken, das an den Rechner anschließen. Das hat dann noch Controller-Ports. Und dann spielt man das Modul aber über den Emulator. Aber man kann halt sein Original-Modul benutzen und kann auch die Speicherstände davon benutzen. Also die Module wurden ja früher mit Batterien ausgestattet, womit man gespeichert hat, weil man ja, ja, das waren ja Roms die Module und man musste irgendwie speichern. Das wurde halt über Batterie realisiert, wenn es kein Passport-System gab. Hat übrigens auch das Problem, dass die Batterien langsam alle werden.
Das heißt, das Rollenspiel, das ich vor 15 Jahren angefangen habe, muss ich dann bald mal zu Ende spielen, weil sonst der Spielstand verloren geht.
Ja genau, genau, genau das. Es gibt natürlich, du kannst die Batterie austauschen. Du musst mal ein bisschen aufpassen, ich habe bei meinen ersten Versuchen jedes Mal die Batterie kurz geschlossen, worauf die Batterie leer war. Dann gibt es so Tricks, wie kann ich die Batterie im laufenden Betrieb austauschen oder wie kann ich es so austauschen, dass beim Austausch meine Speicherstände nicht verloren gehen. Das ist dann so was auf dem G-Moy, wie Spiele auf dem G-Moy Advanced FP, weil die Modulhöhe da nur halb so hoch ist wie beim G-Moy und dann kann man quasi das offene Modul reinstecken und während das Gerät an ist die Batterie austauschen, wenn es halt die ganze Zeit unter Strom ist.
Da geht es einiges an Abenteuer. Du hast gerade gesagt, mit Emulatoren gibt es ab und zu Probleme. Ist das dann quasi nicht mehr die originale Spielerfahrung?
Na, zum einen gibt es halt das Problem, dass, also ich habe mal einen Artikel gelesen, der meint, das ist ein Super Nintendo, was irgendwie mit 2 Mhz oder sowas läuft, braucht einen, um es originalgetreu zu emulieren, einen 3, 1 GHz Rechner oder so. Wenn man alles emulieren wollte von dieser Konsole. Und es gibt halt Spiele, zum Beispiel eben auf dem Super Nintendo gibt es ein Spiel Speedy Gonzales, das kann man auf einem Emulator nicht durchspielen, weil sie es irgendwie nicht schaffen, irgendwas von diesem Spiel zu emulieren und dann bleibt das Spiel mit dem drin hängen. Und bei anderen Emulatoren, also zum Beispiel, ja, wie der Super Nintendo, weil es ist halt schon ein bisschen komplexer, so von den Sonderchips, die da mal mit dabei waren. Wenn die Hardware halt langsamer ist, hat man zum Beispiel bestimmte von diesen Spezialeffekten, die sehen dann nicht mehr ganz so gut aus, bzw. werden halt fehlerhaft dargestellt. Und das hat man natürlich auf der Original-Hardware nicht.
Jetzt würde man vielleicht denken, wenn Konsolen emuliert werden, dann ist das komplizierter, weil da muss ich die ganze Hardware zwischen. Während, wenn ich jetzt, sagen, spiele aus einem alten Rechner, also keine Ahnung, C64 oder Migrant, das müsste ja eigentlich ganz einfach gehen. Das sind ja schließlich alles Computer, die nur schneller geworden sind. Stimmt das so, oder ist das ein Trugschluss?
Also ein C64 läuft ja, das wissen wahrscheinlich deine Gäste besser, der läuft doch auch ein Z80, oder?
Nee, das war 6502 in dem Fall.
Ja, aber sowas wie den Spectrum, der lief ja auf dem Z80. Also es gibt halt Konsolen, die zum Beispiel auf dem Z80 laufen, worauf auch alte Homecomputer liefen, oder ein Mega Drive läuft auf einem 65000er. Das war ein Amiga, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht, der läuft auch mit einem ähnlichen Prozessor. Also da sind, glaube ich, die gleichen Probleme da. Also mit der Homecomputer-Emulation kenne ich mich nicht so gut aus, aber da sind, glaube ich, genau die gleichen Probleme da. Weil man ja bei den Rechnern heutzutage ist ja alles x86-kompatibel, aber früher gab es ja nicht nur Intel-Rechner. Also nicht nur x86-kompatible Rechner, mal abgesehen von so Problemen wie der Geschwindigkeit. Also ich kann mich schon erinnern, als ich auf dem x86 gespielt habe, da ich XT-Spieler nicht spielen konnte, weil die zu schnell ließen.
Also vieles mit Schreiben kenne ich auch.
Die trotz abgeschaltetem Turbo.
Ja genau, trotz abgeschaltetem Turbo war es unspielbar schnell. Alle Freunde von meinem Bruder hatten nur XTs.
Das sind Probleme. Ich habe jetzt noch zwei Fragen. Das eine ist, wenn man da so einsteigen will, diese alten Emulationen von alten Konsolen, wo macht man das am besten? Gibt es da einen einfachen Einstieg? Kannst du was empfehlen an Apps, weil du sagtest, du spielst auf dem Smartphone oder so was?
Also es gibt halt Google. Man sollte googeln, weil das Runterladen der Roms ist. Das ist so ähnlich, wie wenn ich Musik runterlade oder so.
Das wäre jetzt meine nächste Frage gewesen. Wie sieht das eigentlich juristisch aus, wenn man so alte Computerspiele sich anscheinend einfach so irgendwie runterzieht?
Ja, das ist, also es gibt die mehr von, wenn man es nur 24 Stunden zieht, ist es legal oder wenn man halt das Modul, also selbst wenn man das Modul besitzt, ist es wohl nicht erlaubt, sich das Rom trotzdem runterzuladen. Also es gibt zwar einige Seiten, die so alles haben, was das Herz begehrt und die auch über Jahre nicht geschlossen werden. Also es scheint sich niemand drum zu kümmern, aber legal ist es nicht. Deswegen braucht man dann an sich sowas wie die Retro, die es eben erlaubt, das Originalmodul, was man dann auf eBay kauft, auf seinem Rechner zu spielen.
Okay, also es ist eigentlich verboten, aber es kümmert sich niemand drum.
Wer jetzt noch alte Spiele hat, die jetzt keine Hardware-Emulation erfordern, weil sie durchaus irgendwie noch aus den späten 80ern, frühen 90ern stammen, so klassische jetzt wie Indiana Jones beispielsweise, die brauchen auch nicht mehr Hardware-Emulationen. Da gibt es ScumWM, das emuliert nur das Spielesystem. Also dort haben sich dann quasi das Studio oder sogar mehrere Studios hingesetzt und quasi so einen Spielewelten-Interpreter geschrieben.
Ja, Scum funktioniert halt für alles, was von LucasArts ist.
Genau, LucasArts.
Also bis zum letzten Monkey, bis zum Monkey Island 3 oder so. Im Fandango gibt es so einen eigenen Emulator nochmal. Das war so das erste 3D-Adventure in dem Bereich. Und dann funktioniert Scum noch für ein paar andere Spiele. Also das geht auf jeden Fall bei Modulen, also bei den Konsolen. Und es gibt halt die DOS-Box für alte DOS-Spiele. Wenn man da einen USB-Floppy-Laufwerk hat und die alten Floppys noch, oder CDs noch, beziehungsweise bei gog.com, kann man sich die alten Spiele auch kaufen direkt. Da gibt es ja einen Schick mit DOS-Box und Artwork und sonst was.
Warum ich das...
Da kann man die halt direkt los spielen. Da kann man sich die kaufen, runterladen und direkt los spielen. Die haben sich halt um die Lizenzen und alles gekümmert. Bei Konsolen hat man halt immer das Problem, dass man ein Modul hat. Und wie kriegt man das Modul an den Rechner ran? Und Rom-Dumper gibt es halt auch nicht so wirklich.
Also Dinge, die sie sagen, die sie zu kaufen. Nils, dann vielen Dank für diesen Einblick in das Vintage Gaming, könnte man sagen. Und wie heißt er? Retro-Circle.
Retro-Circle, genau. Und dann Retro-Circle.de.
Alles klar. Dann vielen Dank und viel Spaß beim Spielen. Jetzt haben wir auch einen kleinen Ausflug ins Gaming gemacht. Da sind ja hier nicht so die Experten am Start, wie ich mir das sagen lassen. Aber trotzdem an euch nochmal die Frage, dieses rechte Problem. Bei Spielen liegt das so ein bisschen auf der Hand. Das sind halt die künstlerische Werke etc. Ihr arbeitet jetzt mit sehr alten Computern. Bei Windows gab es ja auch immer das Problem von Raubkopien. Wie ist denn das überhaupt bei so ganz alten Computern? Spielt das da auch eine Rolle? Oder spielt das da, wie bei den ganz alten Spielen, theoretisch eine Rolle, aber es interessiert eigentlich keinen mehr? Oder war früher alles open source und jeder durfte damit alles machen? Oder fällt das einfach unter den Tisch und man interessiert sich nicht dafür?
Das spielt schon immer noch eine Rolle. Also die Firmen wurden ja immer aufgekauft und dann wieder von irgendjemanden aufgekauft und abgestoßen und von irgendjemanden aufgekauft. Und die Rechte von den Betriebssystemen und der Software so liegen ganz oft noch bei irgendwelchen Firmen, die man auch erst raussuchen muss, die man gar nicht mehr kennt und so. Aber die Rechte gibt es immer noch und es wäre immer noch illegal, diese Software zu kopieren und zu verwenden.
Haben diese Firmen, die die Rechte dann halten, auch irgendwann Interesse, dass es noch weiter benutzt wird? Und forschen die danach oder hört man von denen eigentlich dann trotzdem nichts?
Teilweise, das kommt ganz auf die Anwendung an, aber ich kenne keinen Hobbyisten, der verklagt worden wäre.
Puh, hoffen wir, dass das so bleibt. Man weiß immer nie, auf was für Komische die in den Leuten kommen. Dexter Runzel, Grad die Stirn?
Naja, also der Punkt ist halt, also ich kenne auch niemanden, der als Hobbyist da überhaupt Probleme mit hatte. Ich habe auch noch nie, bis es da auch keine Fälle bekannt. Aber was ich persönlich halt nicht mache, ist die Disc-Images, die ich anfertige und die ROM-Dumps von meinen Computern. Bei den Computern sollte man das nämlich auch machen, weil die ROMs können sie auch vergessen nach einer Zeit. Die stelle ich halt auf meiner Webseite nicht online, weil ich nämlich da, weiß ich nicht, nicht dass da irgend so ein windiger Rechtsanwalt dann da eine Stelle markt mitmachen zu können.
Also schon aus den Gründen, dass man sich da nicht ausliefern will der unklaren juristischen Situation. Kann das dann auch dazu führen, dass das möglicherweise dann irgendwann in Vergessenheit gerät? Also ich überlege jetzt gerade, du machst das halt nicht. Möglicherweise hast du einen Computer, den du halt letzter hast und wenn du halt keine Ahnung beschließt, ich fahre auf mit dem Scheiß, lösche das alles, dann ist das halt weg.
Der Punkt ist also, man sieht ja auf meiner Webseite, welche Computer ich habe und wenn jemand diesen Computer hat und ein Problem hat, naja, dann helfe ich sicherlich gerne.
Gut, wir werden gleich nochmal über zwei Dinge sprechen, nämlich einerseits darüber, wie es ist, ein altes Internet für Vintage Computer zu nachzubauen tatsächlich und dann nochmal so ein bisschen generellen Rundumschlag zu machen, wie das hin ist, was man an einem alten Computer alles lernen kann. Vor allem noch ein bisschen Musik und danach die Nachrichten.
Zur Zeit geht's bei Fritz um eine der wichtigsten Sachen der Welt.
Shoppen?
Fußball!
Manche machen's alleine, manche zu zweit und einige sogar zu sechs oder acht. Noch ein Tipp. Wohnen? Äh, richtig. Wohnen. Zur Zeit wird hier ungewohnt viel gewohnt.
Vier Wände und ein Radio.
Wer wohnt wie wo? Gar nicht mal so unspannend. Und zu gewinnen gibt's auch was zu gewinnen. Die streng limitierte und unkäufliche Fritz-Fußmatte. Da steht ihr doch drauf. Guckt's euch mal an.
Wohnen Mit Mario Bartsch. Der iranische Präsident Rouhani hat dem Westen vorgeworfen, für das Erstarken des Terrorismus in der Welt verantwortlich zu sein. Vor der Vollversammlung der Vereinten Nationen, sagte Rouhani, militärische Aggressionen gegen den Irak und Afghanistan und eine falsche Einschätzung der Entwicklung in Syrien seien Beispiele für die verfehlte Strategie im Mittleren Osten. Terrorismus sei das Ergebnis von Armut, Unterentwicklung, Demütigung und Ungerechtigkeit. Rouhani hält außerdem ein internationales Abkommen über das Atomprogramm seines Landes bereits im November für möglich. Dafür müsse sich der Westen allerdings flexibel zeigen, sagte Rouhani. US-Präsident Obama hat die Ebola-Epidemie in Westafrika als Gefahr für die globale Sicherheit bezeichnet. Es handele sich um einen Gesundheitsnotfall, der eine internationale Antwort verlange, sagte Obama in New York. Unter der Leitung von UN-Generalsekretär Bahnenberiten hochrangige Vertreter über Hilfen für die betroffenen Staaten. EU-Kommissionspräsident Barroso kündigte an, die EU werde ihre Hilfen um weitere 30 Millionen auf insgesamt 180 Millionen Euro aufstocken. In Deutschland meldeten sich für die Hilfe in den westafrikanischen Ebola-Gebieten laut Verteidigungsministerin von der Leyen bereits etwa 4.500 Freiwillige. Der Etat für Schulhelfer soll laut der Bildungsverwaltung in diesem Jahr um 750.000 Euro aufgestockt werden. Durch diese Erhöhung sollen zusätzliche Schulhelfer Kinder mit Behinderungen im Schulalltag unterstützen. Das zusätzliche Geld soll es laut Bildungsverwaltung geben, weil immer mehr Kinder mit Behinderungen in den Regelschulen lernen. Ihre Zahlnahmen gegenüber dem vergangenen Jahr umfasst ein Fünftel auf mehr als 2.000 zu. Schulhelfer unterstützen beispielsweise Kinder im Rollstuhl auf ihrem Weg durch das Schulgebäude. Bei der Lufthansa drohen wieder Streiks der Piloten. Die Gewerkschaft Cockpit hat heute die gerade erst wieder aufgenommenen Tarifgespräche mit Lufthansa für gescheitert erklärt und Arbeitsniederlegungen angekündigt. Die Gewerkschaft kämpft dafür, dass die betriebsinterne Frührente für die Lufthansa-Piloten nicht abgeschafft wird. Auch die Tarifverhandlungen zwischen der Deutschen Bahn und der Gewerkschaft deutscher Lokomotivführer GDL sind erneut gescheitert. Ob es zu Streiks kommt, entscheiden die Gewerkschafter bis zum 2. Oktober in einer Uhrabstimmung. Die aktuellen Temperaturen liegen in Berlin-Pankow bei 12, in Wannsee bei 14 Grad, Potsdam, Prenzla und Eisenhütten statt Melden 12, Wittenberge 14 Grad. Heute Nacht ist es meist stark bewölkt und es kann hier und da auch etwas regnen. Die Temperaturen sinken auf 12 bis 10 Grad. Am Tag wird es dann wolkig und trüb mit gelegentlichem Regen bei maximal 16 bis 17 Grad. Stadtverkehr Berlin, A100 Stadtring Richtung Wedding. Der Britzer Tunnel ist wegen Wartungsarbeiten zwischen Buschkruge Allee und Gradestraße bis 5 Uhr früh gesperrt. A115 Avers Stadt auswärts zwischen Dreieckfunkturm und Hüttenweg ist die rechte Spur wegen Bauarbeiten gesperrt. Vorsicht auf der A10 nördlicher Berliner Ring Richtung Dreieck-Hafeland. Zwischen Dreieck-Pankow und Mühlenbeck liegen Reifenteile auf der Fahrbahn. Tiergarten, die Straße des 17. Juni, ist zwischen Nizagrabinstraße und Ebertstraße gesperrt wegen des Berlin-Marathons am Sonntag. Und noch eine Meldung von der B158 Angermünde Richtung Berlin. Zwischen Wollenberger Schmiede und Steinbeck gab es einen schweren Unfall. Dort ist die B158 voll gesperrt. Wo es geht, gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn ihr diesen Sound mögt, oder diesen Sound, dann hört doch mal den Fritz Soundgarden mit RGR-Güse. Am Montagabend ab 20 Uhr und im Radio. Oder jederzeit auf fritz.de Musikstreams.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen zurück zum letzten Mal, zur letzten halben Stunde zum Chaos Radio im Blue Moon. Der Sendung, die hier manchmal stattfindet, wo der Chaos Computer Club das Studio übernimmt. Heute in Gestalt von Zeltophil. Hallo und guten Abend.
Guten Abend.
Es geht um alte Computer. Und wir haben schon viel gelernt in den letzten anderthalb Stunden über diese alten Computer, warum man das macht, wie man das macht, was es dafür Probleme geben kann, was man da auch darauf zocken kann, haben wir gerade gehört in der letzten halben Stunde. Und Dexter hat noch sozusagen ein spannendes Projekt gehabt. Er hat nicht nur sozusagen, nicht nur daran, dass man einen alten Computer tatsächlich noch mal jetzt betreiben kann, sondern er hat auch versucht, Internet zu machen für diese Computer. Dexter, bitte, was ist da los? Also erst mal auch hier die Frage, warum macht man das? Weil so ein Internet damals muss doch tierisch langsam gewesen sein.
Ja, das war in der Tat auch sehr langsam. Also das Projekt, was ich da gemacht habe, es hieß Bildschirmtricks. Und da ging es um BTX. Also BTX heißt ja eigentlich Bildschirmtext, aber ich habe das Bildschirmtricks genannt, weil irgendwann hat sich der Chaos Computer Club mal scherzhaft über BTX geäußert und das als Bildschirmtricks bezeichnet. Deswegen hieß mein Projekt so.
Du musst, glaube ich, erst mal ganz kurz erklären, was BTX eigentlich ist.
Ja, ich glaube auch. Also BTX war ein Online-Dienst. Und das war so in den 80ern. Da ist dieser Online-Dienst von der Post gestartet worden. Und das war im Grunde genommen so ein Terminal-Dienst. Also man hatte halt bei den Benutzern, also der Endpunkt war im Grunde einfach ein Terminal. Also im Grunde, naja.
Terminal heißt ein Bildschirm, der nur aus Textzeichen besteht?
Ja, also es ist so ausgesehen, hat das im Grunde wie ein großes Telefon mit einem Bildschirm drin. Also ein Röhrenbildschirm, wohl bemerkt. Und eine Tastatur. Also Volltastatur zur Texteingabe. Und an diesem Terminal hingen Modem, oder das Modem war direkt eingebaut. Und damit hat man dann automatisch, also man konnte nicht selber wählen, was man anwählen will, sondern das hat dann automatisch von der Post, den Großrechner, in Ulm, glaube ich, war der, angewählt und der hat dann eine sogenannte BTX-Seite ausgeliefert, die dann auf dem Terminal angezeigt worden ist. Und da haben, naja, man hat da auch noch nicht so viel Erfahrung mit Online-Diensten gehabt und man hat da also gedacht, ja, man macht dann damit bei, ja, so Versandhausquelle und, ja, man kauft dann online ein, macht Online-Shopping. In Frankreich gab es ein ähnliches System, es hieß Minitel, das war ein Riesenerfolg, das System von der Post ist, naja, gescheitert.
Wie immer, wenn die Deutschen versuchen, was Innovatives im Internet zu machen.
Das ist vor allem an den Preisen gescheitert. Also die Endgeräte waren viel zu teuer und wenn man sich heute so ein altes Endgerät auch ansieht und da reinschaut, dann weiß man auch, warum. Weil da nämlich nur der teuerste Kram verkauft, verbaut worden ist. Also das ist wirklich in alles wunderbar, tolle Technik, aber viel zu teuer für den Endkunden.
Und du hast die nachgebaut?
Ja, also das, ja, im Grunde, das Terminal habe ich nicht nachgebaut. Ich hatte halt irgendwann mal so ein Terminal und habe mir gedacht, okay, es wäre eigentlich ganz schön, wenn man jetzt damit noch, ja, sich in BTX anmelden könnte und ein bisschen, na ja, BTXen hat man da früher zugesagt wohl, also ein bisschen BTXen kann. Und na ja, also ich habe das BTX nie selber miterlebt. Also ich weiß, wusste, dass es irgendwie das gab.
Also ich kenne das auch nur noch davon, dass die Züge, die ICE-Züge, bevor sie renoviert wurden, tatsächlich noch teilweise BTX-Terminals eingebaut hatten. Die waren dann offline, aus ganz unverständlichen Gründen. Aber das war in den ersten ICE-Zügen der ersten Generationen war da tatsächlich vorgesehen, dass man da während der Fahrt BTXen könnte.
Die Zukunft.
Die Zukunft. Mit dem Internet klappt das ja bis heute. Egal, aber wie gesagt, daher kann man das vielleicht mal gesehen haben, weil das da so im Gang mehr oder weniger auffällig so ein etwas Retroteil rumstand. Das ist so ein BTX-Terminal gewesen.
Ja, also wenn man sich so ein bisschen mal vorstellen will, wie das damals wohl ausgesehen hat, dann ist es ganz gut, wenn man sich mal den Tele-Text vom Fernseher anguckt. Das ist so ähnlich war das im Grunde. Also Kletzchen-Grafik, es konnte ein bisschen mehr. Man konnte so eigene Zeichensätze nachladen und ein bisschen Voll-Grafik ging auch. Ja, wie gesagt, ich habe halt so ein Terminal bei mir rumliegen gehabt und wollte das halt wiederbeleben. Also man kriegt die auch in Online-Auktionshäusern eigentlich ganz günstig. Das Problem ist halt nur, die Dinger sind halt relativ tot, man kann damit nicht viel machen. Ich bin dann halt hingegangen und habe mir diese Modems angeguckt. Die hießen DBT-03, das war dieses Postmodem, was da angeschlossen wurde. Habe das so ein bisschen reverse-ingeniert, also ein bisschen im Grunde geguckt, wie das funktioniert, was da für Signale anliegen und in welchen Zeiträumen die Signale angelegt werden müssen. Und da war ziemlich viel, musste man da rausfinden. Also die Baudraten waren bekannt.
Was sind Baudraten?
Das sind die Geschwindigkeiten, wie schnell der Downlink und der Uplink ist.
Wie schnell war das damals?
Also ich kann sein, dass ich mich jetzt irre. Ich glaube, der Downlink zum Terminal war 1200 baut und der Uplink war 75 baut.
Wie viel ist das in Megabyte pro Sekunde?
Das weiß ich jetzt nicht, das ist ganz, ganz wenig. Man kann sehen, wie die Seiten übertragen werden, wie sie sich aufbaut.
Also Zeichen für Zeichen?
Ja, da kann man noch ein bisschen zugucken. Das ist nicht besonders schnell. Da waren zum Beispiel so Dinge drin, wie das Terminal zum Beispiel, also die Hörtöne vom Telefon, also dieses Freizeichen und das Piepsen, das hört das Terminal durch das Modem durch. Da musste man also ein bisschen basteln, bis das mal lief. Das hat sehr lange gedauert, aber irgendwann lief es dann. Und dann konnte ich von meinem PC aus über einen Mikrocontroller, der da als Bautraten-Converter lief, erst mal testweise BTX-Seiten auf diesem Terminal anzeigen. Und der nächste Schritt war dann halt, einen etwas größeren Mikrocontroller daneben zu setzen. Und naja, damals gab es das noch nicht so mit Raspberry Pi und Arduino, das gab es damals alles noch gar nicht. Da hatte halt ein Kollege von mir, der hatte halt gerade so ein Projekt für Mikrocontroller fertig gehabt, wo es darum ging, Internet mit Mikrocontrollern zu machen. Also so richtig Ethernet-Kabel reinstecken und dann auf Webseiten zugreifen via HTTP. Das ging, also das Projekt heißt OpenMCP. Und darauf, der Basis, habe ich dann ein System gebaut, was eben einen HTTP-Request, also im Grunde ein HTTP-Request ist das, was der Internet- Browser macht, wenn er eine Internetseite bei einem Server anfragt. Und da ich auf meinem Web-Server schon diesen Server hatte, diesen HTTP-Server, der normalerweise Webseiten ausliefert, habe ich halt mit dem Mikrocontroller ein HTTP-Request gemacht. Und der Server hat dann halt keine HTML-Seite ausgeliefert, sondern eine BTX-Seite, die ich so ein bisschen HTML-mäßig encodiert hatte.
Aber das Ergebnis war sozusagen, dass du dieses BTX-Terminal quasi benutzen konntest in Originalgeschwindigkeit.
Genau, also das ist ja dann so, der Mikrocontroller hat die Seite entgegengenommen, hat sie dann konvertiert und auf dem Terminal angezeigt. Und dann hatte man eben die Möglichkeit, von dem Terminal aus, diese Seiten auf dem Web-Server anzufangen. Also der Punkt war halt nicht nur, irgendwie einen Mikrocontroller zu haben, wo man irgendwie, der das direkt am PC betreibt, sondern eine autonome Box, die von ihren Abmaßen auch noch in das DBT-03-Modemgehäuse gepasst hat. Das habe ich so gemacht, dass es da reingepasst hat, dass man im Grunde, dem erstmal nicht so ansieht, dass es manipuliert wurde, aber im Grunde eben, dass man ein autonomes BTX-Terminal irgendwo in die Ecke stellen kann und in die nächste Ethernet-Dose einen Ethernet-Kabel steckt und dann im Grunde, wie früher die BTX-Seiten aufrufen kann.
Also es hört sich an wie so eine Art Gesellen- oder Meisterstück des Vintage Computing. Wird sowas irgendwo ausgestellt?
Naja, ich habe mich entschlossen, es auf dem VCFB auszustellen. Da wird es halt dieses Terminal dann zu sehen geben mit dieser Box. Ich hoffe, dass das Internet alles funktioniert. Neue Seiten werde ich jetzt bis dahin wahrscheinlich nicht gestalten können. Da wird man dann irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, wo ich das mal auf den Chaos Communication Box, ich glaube, es war 22C3, vorgestellt habe, wird man diese Seiten dann auch wieder sehen. Das hat auch alles eine bisschen Grenzen. Ich habe es natürlich nur bis zu gewissen Punkten entwickelt, also zum Beispiel Texteingabefelder fehlen. Also man kann BTX mit Nummern und Namen ansprechen. Es gibt automatische Weiterleitungen, aber das war es dann auch schon. Aber doch, eigentlich funktioniert es ganz gut.
Kann man das auch jetzt von aus benutzen oder nur mit diesem Terminal?
Naja, also wenn jetzt jemand sich dieses Projekt, man kann es ja runterladen, sich eine Platine macht und das alles baut und die Firmware da in den Mikro-Controller flasht, dann kann er sein Terminal nehmen, das da anschließend in die Ethernet-Dosis stecken und dann auf meinen Webserver zugreifen und die BTX-Seiten sehen, die ich dahinterlegt habe.
Aber es ist nicht so, dass man sagen, mit einem normalen PC dahinsurfen kann, dann mal BTX quasi emuliert erleben?
Ja, also es geht schon. Man kann natürlich auf diesen HTT-Server zugreifen, aber man kommt dann in dieses entkodierte Format, man kann da eigentlich nichts sehen. Man sieht noch ein bisschen ASCII-Text und ein paar Steuerzeichen, die so in HTML-Textspitzklammern, also es ist eine hexadezimale Zahl, die da ist.
Aber gut, so kann man BTX emulieren. Also, das ist echt ein krasses Projekt. Ich muss mir das mal angucken. Das gibt es zu sehen, wie gesagt, auf dem Vintage Computing Festival Berlin. Sag noch mal kurz, wann das ist, wo das ist.
Das ist am 4. und 5. Oktober im Pergamon-Polley in den Räumen der Medienwissenschaft der HU Berlin.
Okay, da kann man also die ganzen Sachen, die wir heute hier in der Sendung besprochen haben, sich mal sozusagen live angucken, also vielleicht nicht alle, aber sozusagen ein Gefühl dafür bekommen, was das live bedeutet, Vintage Computing zu machen. Ich würde zum Abschluss gerne noch zwei kurze Fragen stellen. Das eine ist, zwischendurch tauchte immer wieder der Name PDP auf, also PDP 11, PDP 8. Warum ist gerade dieser Rechner so wichtig? Also man hat jetzt bei euch viel gehört, aber das ist schon auch ein Name, der wenn man sich so ein bisschen mit dem Computer beschäftigt, der immer wieder mal auftaucht. Was war an diesem Rechner so besonders? Warum ist der jetzt gerade so ein Meilenstein anscheinend? Ist das einfach einer, der noch übrig ist, deswegen mögen Retro-Computer Leute den? Oder war der wirklich so wichtig damals, wichtiger als andere Geräte?
Die PDP 8 war damals im Prinzip der erste Rechner, der sich auch eine kleinere Firma leisten konnte und die auch klein genug war, dass man sie bei sich reinstellen konnte, die nicht einen doppelten Boden brauchte, eine Klimaanlage, die einen normalen Stromanschluss hat und so. Also es war einfach der erste Rechner, der wirklich viel verkauft wurde und ganz viel eingesetzt wurde und auch richtig lange lief. Also PDPs, nicht gerade die 8, aber andere PDPs wurden ja noch bis in die 80er Jahre verkauft.
Und hatte der keinen Nachfolger mehr, dass er so lange durchgehalten hat?
Doch, es gab einen Nachfolger. Das war ein VEX-Computer von Digitell. VEX steht für Virtual Address Extension. Und am Anfang war das tatsächlich eine Erweiterung von der PDP 11, aber später dann eine eigene Architektur.
Aber der war nicht so wichtig sozusagen, weil der ist ja heute gar nicht aufgetaucht.
Der war schon wichtig. Es war auch ein sehr klassischer Industrierechner, der eigentlich auch weit verbreitet eingesetzt worden ist, wo Fertigungsstraßen mitgesteuert worden sind. Auch als Prozessrechner für alles mögliche in der Medizin. Es war im Grunde der Nachfolge dieser PDP-Computer.
Wenn ihr euch jetzt, ihr beschäftigt euch mit diesen alten Computern. Was ich ja feststelle, bei den neuen Computern ist, die wandern immer mehr in den Hintergrund. Man sieht immer weniger, was da überhaupt passiert. Sowohl bei den eigentlichen Computern, die immer dünner und schmaler werden, die man nicht mal einfach aufschraubt und mal eine Festplatte austauscht, als auch Smartphones. Das sind ja auch mittlerweile vollwertigste Computer, die aber sozusagen unsichtbar sind. Also was dahinter passiert. Jetzt habt ihr damit zu tun und seht, geht in die Eingeweiden dieser alten Maschinen. Lernt man oder glaubt ihr, dass das den eigenen Umgang mit Computern verändert? Oder kann man daraus noch was absehen, was sich dann auch heute übertragen lässt?
Also man kann daran sehr viel einfacher lernen als heutzutage, wie Computer eigentlich funktionieren. Ich habe mir aus dem Grund mal ein C64 geholt. Also eigentlich wollte ich eine Demo dafür schreiben, aber habe ich natürlich nie gemacht. Aber so ein C64 ist ein Computer, da kann man noch die Hardware wirklich vollständig verstehen. Da kann man noch verstehen, wie so ein Betriebssystem funktioniert und überhaupt die Software, die darauf läuft. Und daraus aufbauen kann man dann natürlich auch leichter verstehen, wie heutzutage Computer gebaut werden. Aber auch am C64 kann man einfach noch mal was reparieren, mit einem Lötkolben drin rumfuchteln, was man sich in einem heutigen Notebook halt eher nicht mehr trauen würde, weil das alles so klein ist. Und wenn man auch was kaputt macht, zum Teil die Tipps und Bauteile einfach gar nicht mehr kaufen kann selber.
Würdet ihr euch das wünschen, dass heute sozusagen Computer genauso reparierbar sind wie die alten? Oder ist es schon sozusagen jetzt im praktikablen Alltagsgebrauch eigentlich geil, dass man die Maschine halt nicht basteln muss, sondern im Zweifel austauscht?
Na ja, also moderne Computers sind halt einfach Wegwerfcomputer. Wenn sie veraltet sind oder kaputt sind, schmeißt man sie weg. Also wenn man jetzt quasi in der modernen Welt einen Computer haben will, der einfach ist, wo man mit basteln will, dann sind eigentlich Mikrocontroller eine ganz gute Option. Weil das sind im Grunde Computer, die sind so auf dem Leistungsniveau dieser alten Rechner, aber halt auch relativ leicht zu programmieren. Die werden hergestellt, sind halt in Chip-Form. Mikrocontroller ist so ein kleiner Chip. Aber auch da hat man eine Serie-Schnittstelle. Da kann man dann ein Terminal-Programm dranhängen. Und da kann man dann auch, wenn man möchte, ein Betriebssystem programmieren oder eine kleine Shell mit I.O.-Ausgänge schalten, was auch immer. So ein Mikrocontroller ist übrigens auch sehr, sehr praktisch bei Retro-Computing-Geschichten. Zum Beispiel beim BTX-Projekt, da waren auch Mikrocontroller im Einsatz.
Gibt es sonst noch so, wenn man jetzt dieses Chaosradio gehört und sich denkt, okay, ich möchte mir das auch mal näher angucken. Wir wissen schon, wir können zum Vintage Computing Festival Berlin gehen. Aber was sind sonst noch so Anlaufstellen, wo ihr sagt, okay, da kann man hingehen, wenn man sich jetzt anfangen möchte, für dieses Thema zu interessieren?
Man kann natürlich ins Technikmuseum hier in Berlin gehen, da ist aber auch sehr viel hinter Glas und läuft nicht. Man kann in andere Computermuseen gehen. Es gibt das Computerspiele-Museum hier in Berlin. Es gibt das Heinz-Nixdorf-Forum in Paderborn. Es gibt auch relativ kurz noch das Oldenburger Computermuseum. Da kann man auch sehr viel ausprobieren. Da sind sehr viele Rechner, die laufen. Man kann in die Afra kommen zum Vintage-Abend jeden Donnerstag.
Wo ist die?
In Lichtenberg in der Herzbergstraße 55, afra-berlin.de.
Alles klar. Haben wir jetzt noch etwas Wichtiges vergessen zum Thema Vintage Computing? Dinge, die ihr noch unbedingt sagen wollt, die ich nicht gefragt habe? Gut, ich nehme das dann mal als Nein. Was ist euer nächstes Projekt?
Ich habe noch ganz viele alte SGI-Hardware rumstehen, die ich noch nicht mal gebootet habe. Da müsste ich mal mit rumspielen. Und ich habe auch ganz neu eine Microwax bekommen, die habe ich aus Stuttgart so etappenweise nach Berlin geschleppt.
SGI, das war diese Grafikrechnung, wo früher sozusagen die ganzen Special Effects drauf berechnet wurden?
Ja, genau.
Ich habe mal mit einem Fernsehsender gearbeitet, da stand ein so ein Ding rum und das war wie Goldstaub. Sowas hast du jetzt mehrfach zu Hause?
Ja, davon habe ich einiges. Es wird auch SGI Indies mit so einer Indie-Cam zu sehen geben, womit man dann Webchat machen kann, wie in den 90er Jahren.
Großartig. Dexter, was ist dein nächstes Projekt?
Naja, also ich habe einen Xerox 820, den gibt es auch auf dem VCFB zu sehen. Der müsste mal ein bisschen restauriert werden, dass ich floppies Gepäck habe. Möglicherweise mache ich das als nächstes. Und dann habe ich noch so einen Robotronencomputer im Keller. Naja, der ist auch schon, ja der ist ja restaurationsbedürftig, wie das heißt.
Das wollte ich auch noch fragen. Vielleicht könnt ihr das noch ganz kurz sagen. Ihr habt am Anfang gesagt, Home Computer ist sozusagen eine Säule in diesem Vintage Computing. Es gibt aber einen krassen Unterschied zwischen Ost und West. Sind das einfach nur verschiedene Produkte oder gibt es auch sozusagen im Ansatz des Computerns verschiedene Produkte?
Naja, also ich habe den Unterschied sehr deutlich gemerkt, als ich diesen Robotronencomputer mir angesehen habe. Weil das ist ein sehr professionelles Gerät, das ist so ein Bürocomputer A5120 oder so etwas. Wenn man den sich ansieht, dann sieht man eigentlich eine sehr solide, verarbeitete, hochwertige Workstation. Also das ist wirklich ein sehr gutes Gerät, das ist ja auch da für die Industrie gewesen. Also das ist wirklich gut. Allerdings, wenn man sich dann anguckt, in welchem Jahr dieser Rechner gebaut worden ist und was für Fertigungstechnologien, also wie die Platinen aussehen und so, da drin verwendet worden ist, dann sieht man schon diese, ich weiß nicht, wie sie es damals genannt haben, Technologie-Lücke oder so. Also diesen Technologie-Rückstand, den sieht man da sehr deutlich. Das ist sehr interessant gewesen.
Also die waren sozusagen schon von Anfang an Vintage, die Computer.
Na ja, so schlimm ist wahrscheinlich nicht, aber du hast natürlich das sehr häufig gehabt, dass du quasi Nachbauten von Festmodellen hattest und alleine dadurch hast du eine gewisse Verzögerung. Das betrifft jetzt natürlich nicht unbedingt die Fertigung, aber das betrifft auf jeden Fall die Technologie an sich.
Ja, das war zum Beispiel so, dass in diesem Aussatzcomputer ist ja eigentlich ein Z80 drin, aber das war ein nachgemachter Z80, da heißt da irgendwie U880. Ist glaube ich eine 1 zu 1 Kopie, kann man durch ein Z80 ersetzen.
Okay, so, dann sind wir jetzt am Ende gekommen. Ich sage schon mal vielen Dank an Zeltophil und Dexter fürs Vintage Computen. Dannimo in seiner Eigenschaft als Abgesandter des Chaos Computer Clubs hat außerdem noch ein paar Verkündigungen zu machen am Ende. Meine Damen und Herren, Sie sehen bestens vorbereitet, Herrn Dannimo aus dem Chaos Computer Club.
Also mein Laptop ist mir soeben gestorben, aber ich habe hier noch kompetentes manuelles Backup im Formen des Moderators.
Im Formen des Moderators. Du wolltest zum Beispiel was zum Netzpolitik-Jubiläum erzählen. Aha, wolltest du möglicherweise sagen, dass es ein 10-jähriges Jubiläum gibt, das Blogs netzpolitik.org, dass Sie dazu am 17. Oktober in der Kulturboererei Berlin einen kleinen Kongress machen?
So ist das.
Hast du gut gemacht. Dann soll es ein Hackover in Hannover geben. Was ist das? Von 24. bis 26. Oktober, was ist ein Hackover?
Eines der vielen Veranstaltungen aus dem Chaos-Umfeld. Eines der vielen Veranstaltungen aus dem Chaos-Umfeld vom 24. bis zum 26.10.
Was heißt Veranstaltung?
Das ist ein, wie will man das am besten sagen, wer kennt den Kongress? So ungefähr kann man sich das vorstellen.
Liebe Leute von dem Radio, falls ihr euch fragt, was das bedeutet, das bedeutet, da kommen Leute zusammen, halten Vorträge, basteln und sitzen zusammen und quatschen.
Genau und die letzte Verkündigung, die ich habe, ist, dass die Meta-Rhein-Wein-Chaos-Days vorbei sind. Das ist ebenso eine Veranstaltung, wie die vorher genannte. Allerdings, hier kann man sich das Ganze mal anschauen. Auf media.ccc.de gibt es nämlich die Aufzeichnungen dazu.
Okay, jetzt könnt ihr das alte angucken. Wenn euch das gefallen hat, könnt ihr dann zu einem neuen hinfahren. Sehr schön, dann vielen Dank auch dir und vielen Dank dem Chaos Computer Club für's hier dabei sein. Nach uns, nach dem Chaos Radio, kommt Flo Heiler mit dem Night Flight und wird euch mit Gitarrenmusik bewerfen, wenn ich richtig informiert bin. Ich verabschiede mich an dieser Stelle. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter und ich habe noch eine wichtige Nachricht für euch. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschüsselt immer schön eure Backups.